putin ha escuchado las críticas de la
comisión europea diciendo que la vacuna
rusa no es necesaria en el 'viejo
continente' así que el presidente se ha
preguntado si los altos funcionarios
europeos están defendiendo los intereses
de las farmacéuticas o los intereses de
los ciudadanos europeos también ha
criticado putin a la lentitud de la
burocracia europea respecto a las
vacunas que según él está costando vidas
humanas en rusia la vacunación avanza
despacio pero ya hay 6,3 millones de
rusos que han recibido al menos una de
las dos dosis según el presidente ruso
el número total de ciudadanos que ya han
recibido ambas dosis de la vacuna rusa
asciende ahora mismo a 43 millones de
personas el desafío sigue siendo enviar
cantidad suficiente de vacunas a las
regiones rusas asegurar la labor de la
red de vacunación y sobre todo convencer
y continuar informando a los rusos sobre
cómo y dónde pueden recibir la vacuna
porque lo que putin ha aprovechado su
comparecencia para anunciar que se va a
vacunar mañana no ha dicho con cuál de
las tres vacunas rusas el presidente ha
insistido en que en todo caso vacunarse
es una decisión voluntaria y personal